the washing post calls author jody pico
the queen of ethical dilemma fiction
that's a title in her book she tackles
controversial and tough topics from race
relations to the holocaust and school
shootings
her last nine books debuted at number
one on the new york times bestsellers
list
pico's new novel a spark of light takes
on women's reproductive rights
now the book follows a diverse group of
people over the course of one day during
a deadly shooting at a mississippi
abortion clinic
jody pico joins us at the table to
discuss hey jody how are you
so let me tell you this this is what usa
today says about this book a spark of
light
is an uncomfortable disturbing read
abortion is so
highly charged and everybody has very
strong emotions on both sides
right why did you decide that you wanted
to write about this topic
so when i was in college i had a very
good friend who was seven weeks pregnant
unwanted pregnancy and wound up deciding
to have an abortion
which i completely supported years later
i was pregnant with my third child
i too was seven weeks pregnant and i had
a complication and i was told i might
lose this baby
and it was a baby to me and i couldn't
figure out
how i could hold both of those concepts
in my mind at the same time
in america we tend to legislate
reproductive rights
but laws are black and white and the
lives of women are a thousand shades of
grey
and that was why i wanted to write this
book did you want it to be disturbing
you talked to people on both sides i
absolutely did you know this is not an
issue that we are ever going to agree on
and one of the things that i learned
speaking to people who think differently
than me
is that they come from a place of deep
conviction and deep compassion as well
they believe
what they believe and we have to find a
way to work together in spite of that
um what i want is to not tell you what
to think in my book and i
i think if you read the spark of light
i'm not going to tell you there's a
right answer
what i am going to do is make sure that
you hear from the other side and i know
you spoke with dozens and dozens of
people
um did it change your views at all um it
certainly
enlightened me you know i could find
myself having things in common with
people who were pro-life because i
identify as pro-choice
and understanding why they they feel the
way that they do
it didn't change how i feel about
reproductive rights and what i think
women
need uh but the thing that really
surprised me the most and that made me
quite sad
was that i interviewed 151 women who had
terminated a pregnancy of those 151
one woman regretted it all of them
thought about it daily
of those 151 less than 25 were willing
to be acknowledged in the book
and they're living under this umbrella
of stigma and shame
because when women don't speak up people
fill in the story for them
and the narratives are often one of
blame on these kinds of stories of
abortion in particular people cling to
certainty they want
in their opinions and uncertainty makes
people itchy
you have to live in the uncertainty you
have to have it be your whole life
what is that like and does that get
irritating no i
love that actually and and one of the
reasons i was drawn to this topic
is because the uncertainty exists for an
individual woman over the course of her
own life
what you believe at 14 is not what you
think at 30 or at 45.
you know and that's why again i keep
coming back to the fact that
we need to move past legislating
reproductive rights we have to take roe
versus wade off the table leave it alone
and begin to come up with solutions that
that move beyond that
and it's just that i mean nora mentioned
how much research you put into this book
what takeaway from all the researchers
and experts that you talked to
gave you a feeling that maybe this
doesn't have to be such a polarizing
issue
well i think it's in everyone's best
interest to lower the abortion rate
because nobody goes in
wanting to have an abortion right that's
a last resort
and it is its lowest in decades it is it
is although that's kind of a weird
statistic because it's still
rising for disadvantaged women and women
of color socioeconomic exactly
and 75 of women who have an abortion say
it's an economic issue
i think that what we need to do is to
open up conversations about
contraception
as we just heard chelsea clinton say
there are ways to teach sex ed in school
that are age-appropriate
having free and available contraception
lowers the abortion rate
and even spark of light is related to
this issue
right even even the title through me
yeah so that comes from a medical
journal it's a real thing
they are able to see the moment when a
sperm fertilizes an egg under a very
high-powered microscope and when that
happens there is a spark of light that's
released that is zinc
actually and what's cool about it is
that it's something that can be used in
in vitro
the healthiest embryos are the ones with
the biggest sparks well the cover of the
book would be a sparkle light as well
now i mentioned how beautiful it is
and it really is beautiful jody pico
thank you thank you for having me back
really appreciate it another best seller
for you
another one thank you i know so well
spark of light is out
now wherever you like to buy books